a new report shows flavorings used in
many brands of e-cigarettes may be more
harmful than first thought
Boston University researchers found
flavoring additives are directly toxic
to blood vessels and possibly linked to
cardiovascular disease boy the most
popular e-cigarette product is Joule it
dominates with more than 60% of the
market but the company has been
criticized for the device's popularity
with teenagers only on CBS this morning
and a Warner has joules response to
those concerns and a good morning good
morning Gail well Jewell says that it's
a cigarette is designed to help current
smokers switch to something safer and
healthier and the company told us it's
own recent survey shows 64% of smokers
who switch to the product dropped
cigarettes completely but the product is
also popular with teens something Jule
says it never intended Joule is a
product for adult smokers and they have
adopted it Jules Ashley Gould says it's
adults like those featured in the
company's current marketing campaign who
are the products target market since
I've changed the jewel has changed and
my daughter is happy I'm happy they're
mature smokers who say they've switched
from cigarettes to jewel the e-cigarette
that resembles a USB Drive Gould says
the company aimed to eliminate the smell
and social stigma of cigarettes and be
healthier this technology has the
possibility to enable them to continue
to have nicotine in the way it's
delivered in a cigarette without the
combustion and thereby with the promise
of not having to die from it and jewel
has taken off it commands over 60% of
the e-cigarette market what do you think
explains that honestly I think my smoker
finds a product like Joule that works
for them they go and tell other smokers
but something else appears to be driving
Jules popularity to its appeal to kids
on social media teens post photos and
videos of themselves julik with hashtags
like do it for jewel the problem here is
everyone was asleep at the switch
Matt Meyers heads the campaign for
tobacco-free kids and by the time we
woke up we had an epidemic on our
but you call this an epidemic this is
absolutely an epidemic I've never seen a
tobacco related product spread across
this country as fast among young people
as this product a whole new generation
of young people he says who could wind
up addicted to nicotine for life like
Julien Levin dear who says he started
dueling in his late teens after using
other ecig Arats and told us now he
can't quit it's impossible it seems like
it it is a vicious cycle because the
more I use the more I need to use the
harder it will be for me to ever stop
and quit Myers and other anti tobacco
groups also point to joules early social
media marketing that they say echoed
prior big tobacco campaigns with
youthful images and bright colors the
company insists it never deliberately
targeted kids and was caught unprepared
it's a combination of the company was
very small and the product took off very
fast and we had to scale everything in
the company extremely quickly and we're
still frankly working on it today but at
certain point I think people say ok but
now you're not that anymore
isn't there more that you could do
because once kids are addicted most of
them a lot of them are addicted for life
there is more we can do and there's more
we need to do Jewell says it's spending
30 million dollars on youth prevention
programs and is working with social
media platforms to remove images of
teens using the product when we talked
to the company they told us look we had
no idea that this was going to take off
with kids and we don't understand why it
did that's their job when you America
get a product that is highly addictive
knowing the youth tobacco use is a
longtime problem it's your
responsibility our objective is to be a
responsible player in this market I will
take the criticism that we should have
known I will take that criticism but we
know now we're working very hard and we
are committed so this is what a jewel
looks like and a lot of parents are not
aware that this is what it looks like
sort of mimics a USB Drive in many ways
one other area where the company gets a
lot of criticism is flavors yeah so
mango very medley
in addition to sort of tobacco flavored
and mint flavored tobacco anti tobacco
advocates say that you don't need
flavors for adults the company disagrees
and says listen we have lots of adults
using our products who say that they
like it and that's a pod
that's the pod that writes in here
that's the actual flavor one pod has as
much nicotine as a pack of cigarettes
Wow
and the young man we interviewed said I
puff on this all day long
I don't have to go out to the corner to
smoke a cigarette so I use more of it he
says yeah Maya Angelou should say when
you know better you do better so let's
save now that they know let's see what
they do that's what they're got flavors
like creme brulee and fruit medley
that's very appealing I think to young
people that's what some people say all
right no wonder thank you